papa hey how's it goin what's up best
let's play on YouTube let's go thank you
very much we just cuddle up it's every
time everybody
I thought something would actually
happen me coming back here but nothing
happened at all oh no all right what
find 10 yaoi in South Park I only found
like three of them are you kidding me
that can't be my quest I'm leaving
there's no way there's no way that's my
quest sergeant please I changed my mind
are you serious that's my job right now
to found yaoi that is the talk to mr.
Adams in the police station it seems
like we've done all the main quest what
I don't want to do either yaoi I don't
find yaoi I'm not gay Wow
Felix can't believe you just said that
all right supposedly there's a quest in
here so we might as well take it just
let me in let me in it's supposed to be
a weird-looking there yes
hello there we go detective what's your
name
yeah let me know if you need to sit down
to talk things out
okay let's talk things out I understand
that this attention must be scary for
you
you know what else is scared oh my god I
wrote that myself actually do stand up
on the weakest here's my head shot I'm
looking for work you see what's in my
bottom you know what's in my bottom jaw
I'll give you the quests are so weird
distributed mr. Adams headshots to eight
people okay that shouldn't be too hard
we got one here or do we got it wait
sorry I'm that's our quest how do I do
hundred more like you on the force
[Music]
crime doesn't pay kid you're on our team
now right I have to say I'm ugly
impressed with your making oh okay I was
so lost I was like there's no main quest
going on right now there we go we got
gotta go to [ __ ] lair
I don't think it's too far we can go
there scrambles screwed franchise
franchise scrambles screwed
franchise screwed scrambles good
wait there's a new code get scrambles
fast
[Music]
well what about introducing super Craig
in the second Kooning fringe movie
that'd be pretty DC comics of us I
wouldn't recommend it please have a seat
sorry guys can I have a moment with but
lord please wait I'm but Lauren behind
you
[Music]
okay let's talk to Kuhn see what it's
got to sing everybody but Lord I just
wanted to let you know that we've
decided to let you have your own Netflix
series right after the Fast Pass Fox
miniseries and the third [ __ ] and
friends United Nations this is huge
okay well get out there and finish your
girls just wanted to tell you the
exciting news what do you want new kid
you do there's nothing left to talk
about oh no no no no you are not going
to have yes come on three choices new
kid no do not give me those sad puppy
eyes nobody gets to be three classes it
you think that just because you had to
live through your dad [ __ ] your mom
you should get all the sympathy in the
world don't you
I'm sorry I didn't mean to bring that it
if you were going to add another class
what would it be oh hell yeah we need
another class cuz Blaster cyborg it was
terrible
okay we got a close range okay we
definitely don't want elementalist late
night in f1 has grinding power to
fortified teammates and disability I
think we have no psychic on it shut up
whatever I came to sign it is pretty
dumb let's go back in time again back to
when you were just a child you couldn't
sleep that night but it was because you
saw strange lights in the sky you walk
to the mirror
oh man I'm excited for this but these
are so dumb I love it oh yeah then you
heard it strange alien sounds from the
hallway
oh my god you walked out into intruders
an alien my god all right we're an
element in it okay what is this
that's pretty [ __ ] what does that do
though that's awesome that's really good
oh no I can't st. rip let's go
nice oh you think right
impossible moussaka yeah I don't know if
I want to do that well I got to go here
to do it
Oh dolphins Wow which gives me attack I
think I'm over here we got a halt ready
Bailey doesn't even do anything
aah Oh Mac yeah
wow that was so cool
does that skip all their turns and oh
nice he's gonna die and same with him
nice okay okay okay let's start again
didn't they know where the aliens
helping you by showing you who [ __ ]
your mom or were they trying to make you
full of rage you might never know all
right get back out there but Lord you
still have a lot of things to do I don't
think that was worth the three classes
that backstory but you know what I will
take it I will take it and I will shove
it up my butt about but man I remember
some of the stuff that happened in the
first game now that when you were
abducted by the aliens oh my god that
was like too much and when you become a
little mushy you whatever you minimize
yourself that was crazy okay it sounds
like we got to go to the
we got a walk-in are you kidding me okay
let's go to the playground
I thought looking guys we're now at
style in the eighties but the new kids
pulling it up here we are at the
playground nice how did the [ __ ] get
there so fast I didn't come to fight
this visionary architect and a
[ __ ] trader listen to me I
understand the new kid oh no my god
where haven't seen him you might be in
the wrong franchise but if you ever need
help I'll return the favor
you might be in their own franchise
cares about you you belong to a loser
zero income franchise that's run by a
douchebag in a wheelchair you steal it
where is dr. Timothy's phone sorry
freedom [ __ ] that info you guys need to
stop investigating the Chamber of
Commerce and leave it to the
professionals
superheroes oh yeah you guys are the
professional superheroes yeah it just so
happens mysterion that we already have a
connection with Netflix no you don't yes
we do we're just about to get the human
kite and Netflix series off the ground
so no Timmy he's trying to rape my mind
they don't have a connection Netflix
freedom pouch just raped my mind you
guys let's get these pedophile who did
friends it's simple freedom pals unite
never want to go again simple white
tears going down
hello share should have made changes god
damn it I didn't make changes today
all right that's fine alright goes pray
I feel pretty good about my lineup they
really are far away aren't thing
it's not really worth it I'm just gonna
place him here
that's a microaggression right there oh
oh this is awesome
look at this we can suck suck him over
here and then keep doing damage on him
oh my god what is he doing he's
telephoning in fourth-graders second
brannis preschool kids whatever they are
my god they're everywhere
[Music]
come on captain diabeetus come up come
on thank you oh my god I'm so glad he's
dead wait that isn't kill the little
kids are you kidding me I need some kids
to die
oh they die super fast now okay alright
let's kill kill the children
damn that does a lot of damage come here
we go finally my god those so difficult
oh I'm so done with that Jesus it took
me 40 minutes at least and if you ever
want to be part of a real franchise just
call me
[Music]
marvelous better Hey
wait sorry there's boys girls and [ __ ]
go to crunchies microbrew for some
microaggression knowledge I can't wait
this is great stuff it doesn't get
better than this guys and here we are
going to get some info on the macro
grass on this out-of-control Men Pacific
icelandic islander from scandinavia now
i get to change my skin colour tone i
identify as white and white now what the
heck see that wasn't hard was it now
that you know how to define yourself you
can go back to making people pay for not
identifying you and others correctly a
little more about you kid now get out
there kick some ass gosh darn it I don't
think what is this good example for the
young folks
[Music]
fine we have the information we need and
are ready for our next mission
everyone reports there immediately
another [ __ ] lair mission huh
[Music]
and scrambles hmm lucky tiger there you
are Jesus took you long enough
sorry my bad
all right everyone but Lord interrogated
classy and found out our next lead is
that the you store in here in town we
need to infiltrate it tonight that can't
be done why not just you know because
they use door and entrances all lava oh
yeah to do with anything
it's one of his superpowers
hey and to shed said that he owes the
new kid a favor oh my god looks like
you're gonna come in handy again my lord
super Craig right you're not on the team
out of the toolshed tell the new kid is
ready to have his favor returned
everyone else go home and get in bed we
meet at the you store in tonight too bad
if all goes according to plan toolshed
will meet up with you later
just be careful toolshed is a two-faced
backstabbing butt sniffer hmm ah sure
don't know why this is the thing but you
know we got to go back gotta go back
home to sleep this is that we look like
huh pretty [ __ ] all right it's time to
eat dinner and be old depressing [ __ ]
cuz our parents our dad had sex with our
mom can you believe it no meaning it and
an alien showed it to us along with the
baby my god we live a tough life we
changed what is this story news first
asking the counselor about sexual
orientation then talking to the
principal about race confusion was the
point the more our child learns about
the truth the more dangerous it becomes
you stupid Oh on the table pumpkin then
straight to bed you have school tomorrow
there's the underlying plot and a plot
chest twist waiting to happen
but for now let's go to sleep oh nice we
got a lot of cloth we can make a new
outfit listen I know we never talked
about it but your mother and I are very
proud I know we never talked about it
but we're so proud to be Scandinavia I
wish I kept the skin color corruption
and crime rises from the gutters and
fills the streets only one thing to deal
man hashtag yes I agree
let's go browse it's time to change but
this is not really our outfit is it
we're gonna we're gonna change our
outfit cuz I want to look we got a lot
of new stuff actually we have whoa what
in the world is this we can also craft I
believe we could probably craft some
costumes they are SH NEX is pretty cool
the boom boxes oh that's dope we can
actually make that what else did we got
amazing butthole hood and then we had
the Norse oh this is all very tempting
stuff but I do okay okay let's see how
this looks
this is important stuff guys I don't
know if you realize wait where is it
there it is nice since we look so
goddamn stupid that's the issue here yes
yes now we're talking yeah I'm too
Pumbaa excited but sorry I can't stand I
can't stand that stupid facial hair it's
so annoying
okay we're gonna find the keys again to
escape what the heck is our dad doing
of course we gotta use their Hoss
feature to get the key
all right and we're gonna teleport back
anyways the power of farts everyone the
power of farts
they sure love fart jokes in this and
this franchise I guess another key and
that's it I think no we need the copper
key as well where in the world is the
copper key they really barrack here
today well huh they don't want us to go
in out copper key maybe in the kitchen
yes now let's go Braves what in the
world man what's going on there is
indeed we do and it needs to it needs to
[Music]
father was in the garage working on a
project okay huge storm and lightning
blue my father off his workbench
I ran to help him but at that moment
another blast somehow fused his power
tools onto my body I became a superhero
while my father was left mentally
impaired well he sure is mentally
impaired right now and stop keying my
car okay what's wrong with Hanuman this
is different my father's acting even
stupider than ever before perhaps
toolshed wants to help his father
because he feels he could have saved him
all those years ago perhaps
so I have to do this oh they come jr.
yeah oh I never we never been here oh
yes it did it something horrible I don't
even want to talk about it that's okay
you don't talk about it it must be very
painful
it is indeed extremely painful makes
your story seem like a child's goodnight
story anyway let's enter you see there's
lava here I need your help he has a
shortcut to the north of town
I mean that's a lot of Lego regardless
right damn
be careful but held you're dealing with
a bad [ __ ] trader who would but I'm
talking about - [ __ ] - she's a big
[ __ ] traded don't let him trick you
dude can you let it lay off he's helping
answer oh we're in Kenny's house yeah oh
my god I can't seem to walk right with
this character we got some more client
Oh
tweaking Craig fan art
yowee collector Danny what is going on
here
with the pores it generates it can clear
nearly any obstacle okay show me it
looks like there's still lava there but
okay a secret tunnel huh ma'am our look
homeless people we were probably gonna
find him [ __ ] I wanted to attack them
first but whatever we can kill me only
so many tool base one-liners in the
world you know yeah there you go that
was good no no that was good
that's my double screw it Pierce's in
both directions huh
that was very neat buddy very nice body
somebody's about to get fixed who's it
gonna be
there it is nice very nice
oh yes that's how it's done Oh mom mom
aren't you glad you're watching this huh
best best doesn't get back it couldn't
be better actually let me adjust my
artifacts while you shut up okay shut up
I still have these shitty ones
okay well let's keep going
all right where are you taking me hmm
through here more lava yeah yeah oh my
god it's those guys should stay on the
new kid what fine as long as there's a
power generator nearby I can use my
dad's sand blaster to clear almost any
obstacle wow that is good Wow
that is indeed fantastic [ __ ] and
friends after tonight were sworn enemies
again fine there's damn cats I forgot
that was supplied because I'm so
invested in saving this cat I want
nothing more in my life than to save
this damn game thank you hey there's a
key there let's try that right that
calendar oh my god it's beautiful look
at that candle in there for a second
okay what else do we got in here main is
the same that was a bit too easy wasn't
it [ __ ] we have a really cool costume
though right like we don't need to that
is pretty dope ours is cooler okay I
know what's cool guys trust me I know
it's cool I'm wearing a cap backwards
alright it doesn't get cooler than that
alright what are you wearing then huh
but you're wearing underwears on your
face too dummy that is indeed what is
this
oh my god we're left in it's a trap it's
a trap everybody emitted [ __ ] French
[Music]
hams are so cute oh my god yes no don't
let me kill them that is a lot of
hamsters I'm a cat
we're surrounded this is Dan let's keep
going through whoa this is dope
I love what you've done with the place
oh my god
this is dope oh yeah we need a captain
diabeetus penis right
let's need to get here damn his face ah
I never get comfortable - this will go
back in time so we can keep going now we
didn't forget
[Music]
where's the stupid cat can't it's locked
oh there's something here oh my god what
is the Oh its actual minions is that all
those hooks are ten fall on them okay
this should be a cake in the Tate
Timberlake they have CDs on them damn
those dogs are from the future nice just
the dog left it was
what are they Mexican oh look at that
[Laughter]
it's cute
these babe when dinero
oh I missed one and it's gone down dick
King
sorry Mexicans I'm sorry if you're
Mexican and watching this just know that
I don't condone with this horrible
prejudiced bad thing think ok alright ok
now we can go in here of course of
course
the dam can't better be in here is all
I'm seen oh I forgot the pause you're a
dead power fart pouch it's a very good
ability you can go through and hit the
switch very nice
oh look how many weapons do we need
these
[Music]
what what do you used to get past there
oh I see I see I see no my bed of course
I got to move on fire so I'm so dumb
come here dynamite did you know that
dynamite is a Swedish invention you're
welcome well you're welcome
and it was discovered by accident err it
is very nice where's the bleeding cat
okay let's get Kyle's
fart scoring Tim so dumb I can't even
yeah
all right let's keep going on a night
event I'd avenge your bed a very rare
shut up
wait sorry how how do I get them what oh
my go
my god shut up man you don't know me
there's something here yes of course
genius I'm a genius man oh my god
Hey look at that okay I'm not gonna go
back at camp it but there that's too far
to walk
nice let's take all day I got a feeling
there's a strong bass incoming there's
no tool there hmm can we go here
super Craig yes we do [ __ ] it dad
[Music]
call girl the owner is a part of a new
crime syndicate oh [ __ ]
it's that cold yeah well she's not in
the Union excuse me are you on Instagram
someone new in town who's bringing all
the crime families together okay cool
thank you back you mean like a kingpin
you guys do not say anything tough not
playing with her check out storage
facility 50 60 new kids in here take
this call me if you need me I think
you're gonna need all the help you can
get
so I guess now any [ __ ] [ __ ] thinks
they can be a superhero well pretty much
just find scrambles and be done all
righty then we're gonna end that episode
there hope you enjoyed it really
appreciate a like and comment whatever
all the support has been amazing really
appreciate you guys it's still fun to
play this for you and it's a fun thing
for everyday and I hope you're enjoying
the ride as well as see you tomorrow
good day back